the Joe Rogan experience it's all about
grandmother's take your power
grandmother's yes every grandmother in
this country is responsible I figure for
between 15 to 100 people a woman who
lives that long and keeps her family
around her that's exactly what happens
and it's the truth of it so I call that
a community you know depending on where
they are geographically that community
in the words of Malcolm X why I ran for
president on that party it needs to
create community health and community
sovereignty and community what's the
word work it just keeps going momentum
and now it I can't think of the word but
it's a kind of farming where it's just
like it feeds itself it's self
generating do you know what I mean mmm
the economy of that particular community
is self generated good bread since the
pineapples you grow you sell at your the
market right are that kind of thing but
sustainable sustainable thank you I
couldn't think of that word getting old
sucks man
those were many you know you vented a
good word what was it again synchronous
synchronous artists yes we're gonna use
that one but we're doing that we try to
do that in Hawaii where we we create we
create not an artificial economy but a
barter economy and of course it's all
based on land as is all wealth and
because you can grow [ __ ] and feed
people and that's what matters so the
biggest problem facing us as humans is
how do we get the food in front of the
hungry kids that's our problem but we go
to all this other [ __ ] rather than that
so we need to start over get
grandmother's in charge every
grandmother there'll be a community
grandmothers organization all based on
the nation of Iroquois which was how the
United States was actually founded
because Benjamin Franklin was a fan of
the Iroquois people in the way they ran
their government which was run by a
grandmother's council and that's what he
invented the thirteen
you know they came up with the 13
colonies United because it was 13 tribes
and the Iroquois were the judge
[Applause]